don't you let that dog piss on my
walkway he has no idea who's doing that
well it was one of you
[Music]
no don't you dare let that little red
dog piss on my walkway again ignore him
Prince he has no idea who's doing that
well it was one of you
get out of here
you cannot use this road without a
permit have a nice day sir you know the
other guys don't do this the guys with
the white trucks how come it's always
you brown guys and I don't mean that
racially
I'm sorry you didn't get any earlier the
whole neighborhood has fallen apart
these days
[Music]
oh my God give me the keys hello hello
what's your name Otto
Otto
Otto I'm Abby o-t-t-o
got some new neighbors right an Edward
husband
I brought you some food okay bye
are you always this unfriendly I am not
unfriendly okay you're not every word
you say is like a warm cuddle
[Music]
can you please give me a ride I don't
have a license you don't have a driver's
license how old are you
[Music]
almost hit the car that's all right
how did you get in here
no no no you are not taking over my bed
I was wondering if you could help us out
thank you
I'm not sure about this it's gonna be
very fun
how was it you did a good job you should
pat yourself on the back
[Music]
I have a cat
do you think you have to do everything
on your own guess what no one can
pepper
you want to see a trick yeah can I
borrow a coin what did you do
it was all the Clown's fault
[Music]